quand tout le monde semble faire quelque chose de mieux
que vous actuellement.
Mais il y a un autre « FO » à redouter,
bien plus dangereux.
« FOBO »,
« Fear of a Better Option », la Peur d'une Meilleure Option.
[Les mécanismes de nos comportements]
Nous monde est submergé par les choix.
Les décisions si simples auparavant,
choisir un restaurant ou faire nos achats quotidiens,
sont devenues cornéliennes avec la sur-analyse.
La technologie a accentué le problème.
Acheter des lacets blancs en ligne
nécessite de passer en revue des centaines d'articles
et de lire des centaines de commentaires.
Un volume stupéfiant de données à traiter,
tout ça pour acheter des lacets, moins chers que votre café du matin.
Vous savez ce qu'est FOBO si l'indécision vous a déjà pétrifié
devant un choix entre deux solutions parfaitement acceptables.
C'est le symptôme d'une culture qui valorise
la collecte et la préservation du plus de choix possible.
Pourquoi est-ce si mauvais ?
N'est-ce pas contre-intuitif ?
Avoir trop de bonnes options entre lesquelles choisir
n'est-il pas un privilège ?
Le problème est : FOBO induit une paralysie analytique telle
que cela dégrade votre vie personnelle et professionnelle.
Ne pas parvenir à une décision avec conviction
nous fait perdre temps et énergie.
Mais on peut vaincre FOBO.
Voici le secret.
Face à une prise de décision, déterminez les enjeux.
Ceux-ci vous guideront pour déterminer une stratégie.
Fondamentalement,
nous avons trois types de choix dans nos vies :
ceux aux enjeux importants, faibles ou inexistants.
Prenons les décisions sans enjeu.
Il s'agit des détails mineurs
pour lesquels il n'y a pas de mauvaise réponse
et rapidement, on ne se souvient même plus
avoir pris une décision.
Que regarder à la télé, par exemple.
On est aisément submergé par les milliers d'émissions.
Quel que soit notre choix,
il n'y a pratiquement aucune conséquence.
Passer plus de quelques secondes pétrifié par FOBO
est un énorme gaspillage d'énergie.
Il faut avancer.
Quand il n'y a pas d'enjeu,
la solution est de s'en remettre à l'univers,
comme réduire le choix à deux solutions
et décider à pile ou face.
Ou, comme j'aime le faire, demander à votre montre.
Il s'agit d'assigner un choix à chaque cadrant
et d'abandonner le choix à la petite aiguille.
Aujourd'hui, du poisson au menu.
Passons aux décisions avec des enjeux faibles.
Il y a certes des conséquences mais rien de catastrophique.
Il y a plein d'issues acceptables.
De nombreuses routines professionnelles, l'achat d'une imprimante,
la réservation d'un hôtel ou le choix d'un lieu
ont des enjeux faibles par nature.
Il faut un peu réfléchir
mais aucune délibération de vie ou de mort.
Vous aurez tout oublié d'ici quelques semaines.
Vous pouvez même déléguer la prise de décision.
Il faut juste un peu d'esprit critique,
comme il y a un peu d'enjeu.
Si vous déléguez,
déterminez quelques critères,
sélectionnez une personne qui vous donnera un avis
et suivez-le.
Évitez la tentation de tout cadenasser
car vous voulez vous alléger
mais pas procrastiner.
Maintenant que vous avez géré les décisions peu importantes,
vous avez le temps et l'espace nécessaires
pour gérer les décisions importantes.
Quelle maison acheter ?
Quel travail accepter ?
Les enjeux sont grands avec des conséquences sur le long terme.
On ne veut donc pas se tromper.
Avant de commencer, établissons quelques principes
pour nous guider dans le processus.
Pensez d'abord à ce qui est primordial
et établissez vos critères sur cette base.
Collectez les données pertinentes.
Veillez à obtenir les infos pour toutes vos options
pour garantir
une prise de décision en connaissance de cause.
Enfin, souvenez-vous que la nature de FOBO
s'exprime quand vous hésitez
entre un petit nombre de choix parfaitement acceptables.
Quel que soit votre choix,
vous aurez la certitude que les inconvénients seront limités.
Après avoir établi ces règles de base,
entamez le processus.
Laissez d'abord votre intuition identifier votre préférence.
Comparez chaque autre choix un par un
avec votre préférence.
À chaque fois, choisissez le meilleur des deux sur base de vos critères
et abandonnez l'autre option.
Voici comment éviter FOBO.
Quand vous éliminez une option, c'est définitif.
Revenir sans cesse aux choix abandonnés
risque de vous bloquer.
Répétez le processus jusqu'au moment où vous obtenez le choix final.
Avec ce système,
vous arriverez souvent à votre propre décision.
Quand vous serez bloqué, rarement toutefois,
déléguez la décision finale
à un petit groupe de personnes de confiance
aptes à vous offrir leur avis
sur ce sujet précis.
Discutez avec un nombre impair de personnes si possible, 5 ou moins,
pour obtenir une majorité si nécessaire.
Une fois votre décision prise, il reste un défi :
vous devez vous y plier.
Je ne peux pas promettre que vous saurez si vous avez pris la décision parfaite
mais je peux vous dire
qu'un pourcentage significatif de personnes dans le monde
ne souffrira jamais de FOBO.
Contrairement aux millions de personnes qui ont peu ou pas de choix,
à cause de la guerre, de l'indigence ou de la maladie
vous jouissez d'opportunités pour vivre selon votre libre arbitre.
Vous n'aurez sans doute pas tout
mais le simple fait de pouvoir décider est source de pouvoir.
C'est même un don.
Ne le gaspillez pas !